any type of pandemic the government may
expand its control over individuals to
serve the greater good but what about
the danger to civil liberties and
finding a balance
well that debate is playing out in New
York where the city is far left mayor is
thinking about locking the entire city
down but so far the governor says not on
his watch no city in the state can
quarantine itself without state approval
and I have no interest whatsoever and no
plan whatsoever to quarantine any city
all right let's debate the delicate
balancing act with former Deputy
Assistant Attorney General John you and
Seattle radio talk show host Jason
Raines welcome back to both of you good
to see you Shannon I thought I was
interesting I was looking around today
for information about quarantine and
things from the past they stumbled upon
this document from the ACLU that they
put together in 2008 called pandemic
preparedness they say this too often
fears aroused by disease and epidemics
have justified abuses of state power
highly discriminatory and forcible
vaccinations and quarantine measures
adopted in response to outbreaks of the
plague and smallpox over the past
century have consistently accelerated
rather than slowed the spread of disease
while fomenting public distrust and in
some cases riots Jon that's a that's
quite a mouthful this is we could look
at history and yes we could learn from
events in the past but those are times
when people didn't know about germ
theory for example I think what you have
before you now is a much better way to
learn which is to look at what other
countries have done for example dr. oz
just lo hago said South Korea has done a
good job China has now turned the corner
on it where we can also learn from
places like Italy where policies seem to
afield we don't have to go back and look
a hundred years or 50 years at panics
and a lot we can look at the evidence
before us and I think there are certain
policies which seem to be working but we
can go too far I'm living here in San
Francisco in the Berkeley area where we
seem to be under a total lockdown of
almost all social activity that might be
going too far but I don't think it's a
violation of constitutional rights I
think instead we're trying to reach
right bounce between stopping the spread
of a disease but also not totally
putting the economy into a seizure so
that people who need money who need to
work aren't able to the Washington Post
under this headline the government can
quarantine you for coronavirus and
there's almost nothing you can do about
it says this regulation set forth by the
CDC give health officials broad
authority to quarantine or isolate
anyone quote reasonably believed to have
been exposed to a range of highly
infectious diseases the list includes
flus that can cause a pandemic
now Jason I know you're out there on the
west coast to where you've got a big
explosion of this and there are some
measures in place how's it plan out
there so right now it's playing out in
the way that you expect it to lots of
people are nervous lots of people are
than the brink of panic we heard earlier
today that the schools may stay close
into the fall we constantly are hearing
rumors about a San Francisco style
policy that will keep people indoors you
walk around drive around the city of
Seattle it's unrecognizable there are
not that many people out on the roads
they're certainly not people in
businesses and a lot of them have had to
shut down and there's a fear that
they're not going to open up again and
so not only are we dealing with the
health concerns and the panic about a
potentially deadly virus depending on
the demographic that gets it but you're
also now worried about paying rent
paying just common bills and going about
your normal life and I think at some
point they're going to intersect in a
way that needs to be managed and I'm
wondering if we're prepared for that
we're gonna play something by the
Surgeon General today here's his take on
us and we are not an authoritarian
nation so we have to be careful when we
say let's do what China did let's do
what what South Korea did a lot of our
public health authority lies in the
state and local level you know and John
I've been hearing this debate back and
forth people saying like look the states
are doing everything because the feds
aren't managing it well and the other
hand they're saying listen you're gonna
watch this Trump administration they
have all these authoritarian tendencies
and you can't let them start you know
cracking things down from on high from
the feds I mean John where do people
find that balance firstly it's ironic
that people are attacking Trump now for
not being activists enough when just a
few two months ago people are attacking
Trump trying to remove him from office
because they've heard he was exercising
too much presidential power so it's a
good point that you're making Shannon
because there is a difference between
what the federal government can do and
what the state government can do the
federal government can control the
borders it can provide a lot of money it
can provide a lot of supplies but the
real power of government here to handle
an epidemic like this it's not localized
in one place that's spreading out
throughout the country is in the state
governments that's the way our
Constitution was designed and federal
law still gives the frontline
responsibilities to governor's mayor's
County executives because they're the
ones who control the resources and the
personnel that can really enforce things
like travel restrictions that can shut
down businesses the federal government
doesn't have the people or the resources
to do anything like that so in a weird
way to success for the president for
Trump and dealing with this epidemic is
really going to lie in the hands of
people like Gavin Newsom our Andrew
Cuomo
yeah with which interestingly enough
they both have had praise for him over
the last few days and their arch enemies
otherwise okay speaking of governors a
governor Northam Virginia tweets this I
just issued an emergency order with Vth
Commissioner to enforce Virginia's
statewide ban of more than ten patrons
in restaurants theaters and fitness
centers
please use common sense if you were
considering ignoring this limit don't I
mean Jason at what point do you have any
concerns about authorities using
whatever you know resources they have at
this point because they're you you know
being channeled in a lot of important
areas but to crack down on people who
don't you know go along with what is for
now a voluntary at least in where you
know we are in here in Virginia a
voluntary suggestion so here's where I'm
concerned I'm concerned when people
decide that they don't think this is
serious enough to do the self isolation
I fear that some people are going to put
the governor's or mayor's in positions
where their hands are tied and they're
going to start to move down the line of
these kinds of massive quarantines I've
been talking to people on my radio show
on both sides on the left I need to hear
people stopping this nonsense
politicking and going after Trump
wherever they can and taking it out of
context because they're downplaying the
seriousness of this on the right I say
the same thing and I'm conservative but
I'm talking to folks on my side saying
let's chill out a little bit about any
type of criticism against the president
there are good-faith criticisms that we
can level and stop with the conspiracies
that all of a sudden the police are
gonna take over and we're gonna have
people with guns wandering around the
streets keeping us in our homes we're
not going to that point but if we don't
take this seriously if we don't follow
the directives coming from public health
officials coming from this
administration and coming from our
governors I think we're going to force
their hands I know that folks like John
are out there who are going to make sure
that if there are any legitimate civil
liberty disruptions they're going to
call this out but right now I'm more
concerned about the guy that you played
earlier don't get on a beach and hanging
out yeah we got to leave it there thank
you both for weighing in it's an
important topic we'll continue the
discussion thank you